foreign
that some of you may or may not have
heard about which is a bit of an
offshoot of the decolonizing education
movement and particularly the
decolonizing science movement so before
that let me introduce myself hi my name
is chandrima Ganguly and I am a research
fellow in cosmology at the University of
Cambridge so obviously I am very very
engaged with the pursuit of Science and
honestly I call myself a scientific
historian in a way because cosmology is
a study of the origin of the universe
so to begin with
um I'd like to ask you a question
according to you let me have a show of
hands is science objectively true
wow okay okay four three four people
nice let's see if I can change your mind
next question do you think planes fly I
mean I understand that this is a bit of
a leading question because there is a
picture of a plane that is clearly
flying but again let's have a show of
hands do you think planes fly
yeah most of you think planes fly and
most of the time you'd actually be
correct but
um there are sometimes a few fatalities
where planes don't fly
um about 140 planes between 2012 and
2016 didn't actually manage to fly
um so the statement that planes fly
isn't exactly right what I can say is
that most of the time and we can
quantify this with Statistics planes do
manage to fly
now this is a bit of an obtuse example
right because
um I can actually look at the number of
planes that are flying I can count them
I can count the number of planes that
don't fly and I can give you a really
good estimate of How likely it is that
when you board a plane you'll actually
manage to arrive safely at your
destination
an example a little bit of how we use
statistics to understand
experimental results or Draw scientific
theories or hypotheses and prove them
this method gets a little bit
complicated when you apply it to certain
questions that science seeks to answer
and one of the questions is the question
that I research that is how did the
universe begin
now the obvious problem with this of
course is that unlike in my example of
the planes I can't actually do direct
experiment or observation of the very
beginning of the universe
what I have to do is that I have to
assume a theory and assume that that the
laws that govern physics in fact physics
as a paradigm itself remains valid right
till today and I have to infer results
and figure out how the universe could
have begun already this becomes a bit
more of a complicated process because
I'm assuming models I'm I'm assuming
paradigms I'm using a statistical model
in order to verify my model given some
data that is true today
so already the scientific method that
I'm using for simpler situations
starts to become a little bit more less
objective if you like
so the question I just asked you was
about whether science was objective
science is
not usually objective but the problem I
have is that the way we qualify good
science
we use that as a synonym for objective
science
and I actually think that's a problem in
the way we communicate science from the
scientific Community to the
non-scientific community and so actually
I'm going to call for a call to action
any people who belong to the scientific
Community to be transparent about the
science that we do and its possible
limitations when we communicate it out
to our broader community
and to those of you who consider
yourselves to be on the outside of the
scientific Community I think it's
important for you to investigate
scientific claims and it and inform
yourselves about its possible
limitations
this this concept will become really
really important in my next section
because the next question I'm going to
ask you is who is a good scientist fun
fact I actually Googled good scientists
and this was one of the top hits
um in my world view if I could make the
rules for this a good scientist would
kind of look like this but unfortunately
I don't get to make the rules and this
is actually a problem because as I'm
sure most of you are aware most
scientific disciplines definitely my
discipline and theoretical physics and
maths is biased towards only a certain
kind of person
so this sort of culture around this led
one of my colleagues Chandra Prescott
Weinstein to write on her blog about the
culture that permeates cosmology and she
calls it toxic masculine cosmology
now the words toxic and masculine don't
only refer to the kind of people or how
we populate the academic hierarchies
within cosmology with CIS white
heterosexual men but also the culture
that permeates a science we do
you see in my experience the way we do
science is that we try to push forward
an idea of invulnerability of being
absolutely correct of of never showing
weakness or ever showing a possibility
of being wrong
but the point is that we don't even know
what's right science is not objectively
true we are all subject to human bias
we're all subject to our cultural
backgrounds as a scientist as you will
see later on in the talk so what are we
really pushing forward this imagined
version of strength towards
also
because of this idea of an objective
truth that is put forward through
science we also have this idea of a
meritocracy
now something that is considered
meritorious is seen as something that is
going closer and closer to this idea of
objective truth as pushed forward by
science
but as we just said that's that's
objectively not true if you excuse the
pun so why are we populating our ranks
with this idea of meritocracy which is
in fact arbitrary and the metrics that
measure this Merit are also created by
again the majority of people who have
populated the scientific ranks
because of this actually
the culture becomes extremely
inhospitable
and this in my opinion leads to
statistics like these which are actually
really awful when you think about it
this shows a number of Hispanic women
and African-American women who were
enrolled in astronomy degrees from 1997
to 2016 in American universities this
sadistic published by the American
Institute of physics there were less
than 10 African-American women who were
enrolled in bachelor's degrees in this
between 2012 and 15.
now I don't think we can combat this
problem by just saying that let's have
more women of color let's have more
queer people doing astronomy there's
obviously this problem goes far deeper
than just simple diversity the culture
has to be a culture of inclusion whereas
if we keep holding on to these ideas of
arbitrary objectivity arbitrary merits
we will end up by definition excluding
the majority of people and to me that is
not a way that you can do good science
so my second call for Action to the
scientific Community is to make hiring
decisions and not just within the
academic ranks or Industrial Research
ranks but also when recruiting students
not just based on Merit because as we
just said that's a matter of decision
and choice but also are based on people
who are truly committed to changing the
culture in which we do science
now in order to progress with Sciences
I'm sure you will be hearing about more
in the rest of this Festival we need a
paradigm shift particularly in the
fields of theoretical physics if we have
only one type of person with a very
limited view of of The Human Experience
we will not be able to achieve this
paradigm shift
furthermore the way we distribute power
and privilege is in itself an
exclusionary process
when someone gets a job when someone
gets into the University of their dreams
when somebody gets into a tenant
position there are lots of people who
gets pushed out based on this idea of
Merit how are we ever going to build an
inclusive scientific Community unless we
tackle the fact that hierarchical
distributions of power themselves are
exclusionary so ultimately my dream I
think to have to build a more inclusive
community is also dismantling
hierarchical distributions of power
ultimately as a scientist I think we're
all here to try to understand nature
better and that is our great equalizer
so with that I think what I am
advocating for is a changing climate I'm
not advocating for increased greenhouse
gas emissions I think we have had enough
of that but we need to change the
climate in which we not only discuss
science within the community but the way
the larger Community perceives
scientists and science
I have no patience for constructing a
deification of any Institution
I do not think we should be deifying
scientific institutions and saying
things like we believe in science
science is not a matter of belief it is
a matter of question and you must be
skeptical of every claim that anybody
makes whether or not they have a bunch
of scientific degrees or not
and only then I think as a community
effort can we actually move forward in
Making Science a more inclusive and
actually a place that is better able to
content with the challenges that are
coming towards us from lots of
socio-political and economic fronts
so with this let me introduce the
program of decolonizing to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV